and tonight the phillies turned to their
number one prospect spencer howard well
philly fans have been clamoring for this
guy for weeks and weeks
for spencer howard to come up and take a
spot in the rotation well
joe girardi dave dombrowski guess what
here's his audition
it'll be [ __ ] hernandez to lead things
off big swing and a miss there is the
fastball
three pitches to strike out [ __ ]
hernandez one down
here is rafael devers one two
changes it up that time off speed
delivery and it's back-to-back case
for spencer howard in his first start of
the year the 1-2 on the way to martinez
swung on and hit in the air to center
straight away
now over to his left goes o'double he'll
make the catch
sides retired a good start for spencer
howard one two
three go the red sox will have to do it
against one of the hardest throwing
starting pitchers in all the baseball
nathan giovaldi looking for his first
win
since april the 30th one away and
that'll bring up gene segre no score
here in the bottom of the first here's
the 1-1
swung on hit of the air right center
field pretty well hit santana on the run
to the gap he won't get there he's going
to one-hop the fence
and into second goes gene segura he's
there with a stand-up double and uh
gene segura flipped the switch
apparently last night
and uh now four for five here comes
bryce harper
two and two evaldi throws swing and a
miss he struck him out
96 mile an hour fastball at the top of
the zone
big second out and harper is gone
the bogart santana and bobby dahlback so
howard holm and he went off speed
79 miles an hour to get boguards to
swing through
three strikeouts in the first four
batters for spencer howard
this is nasty and santana will go back
to second and get the stolen base
and that one is in there for a called
third strike
again change-up that's up in the zone
but all that caught looking and there's
strikeout number four
and that'll bring up the left fielder
francie cordero
another change-up from howard and he has
struck out the side
in the second five strikeouts
for the 24 year old from san luis obispo
five strikeouts
through the first seven batters six of
the seven have seen a first pitch strike
deal with kevin plawecki oh he snares
that comebacker off the bat of clowecki
just one base runner through the first
eight boston red sox batters one away in
the third
yavali and hernandez aboard with now
this
core of the red sox lineup coming up
devers is up this is a definition for
disaster here for
howard after cruising through basically
the first eight hitters
devers lifts it down the right field
line long run for
harper on his way dies
could not hold on to it javoldi all the
way around
throwing a third not in time the red sox
have a one-nothing lead
bases loaded for zander who struck out
at a change-up his first time up
the 02 swinging a fly ball left center
field should be deep enough to get a run
home mccutchen moves to the gap to make
the catch
and [ __ ] tags and scores and the red sox
lead at two nothing so xander gets
his 29th rbi three out opening the third
it brings up segura
and there's strike three fastball over
the outside corner at the knees that was
almost the same pitch as the previous
one
but this time nate got the call that's
his second punch-out and here's harper
who struck out for the first time
that time he goes with the off speed
pitch in the dirt harper chases
he has struck out twice and it's a one
two three third inning for ivaldi
he's at 68 pitches and indeed joe
girardi is going to have the hook
for the 24 year old fill it in getting
the
start tonight his first of the season
and just the seventh of his major league
career
that'll do it for the 24 year old three
innings plus one batter
there's a bullet down the line past dull
back a base hit
for brad miller into the corner he's
gonna round second gunning for three
a one out triple a stand up three bagger
for brad miller
phillies will bring the tying run to the
plate here in the bottom of the fourth
double herrera who walked his first time
to extend his on bay street
the pitch swung on hit in the air center
field santana back into his left he'll
get there
makes the catch miller tags he'll score
easily and o'double gets the phillies on
the board a sacrifice fly it's his
seventh rbi of the season
and the phillies cut the lead in half
it's now two to one boston
speaking of crushing it this guy has not
allowed a run at citizens bank park
going back to 2019.
sam coonrod he's got to deal with
boguard santana and dalbeck here in the
sixth
pitch is swung on and hitting the air to
right field back it goes toward the wall
looking up is harper it's gone
it carried out an opposite field home
run for xander bogart
and the red sox have a three to one lead
his league leading 56th hit
and the red sox are ahead three to one
now they get the run
back now santana goes deep the other way
herrera racing back back to back both
sox bombs it's
four to one santana goes back to back
with xander and the red sox lead at four
to one
opposite field shot from the left side
for danny santana
as he hit it to left center and 4-1 red
sox they go back to back
and that'll bring up reese hoskins
first pitch swinging hammers it to left
home run number 100
for reese hoskins his ninth home run of
the season
and rhys hoskins has hit number 100 in
his big league
career and that's got to feel good to
get that monkey off his back
no doubt about it first one allowed by
ivaldi it comes to hoskins
on a signature milestone mark and
that'll do it for nathan yavaldi
the home run drought against nathan
yvaldi
ends at 68 plus innings
here's the pitch swinging the ground
ball deep short diving therese he's got
it
hops up long throw to first hoskins digs
it out he got
him wow what a play by ronnie thereas
deep in the hole a full out
dive hops up and throws out martinez for
the second out
tremendous play right i didn't think he
was going to have a chance to catch it
segura is hit and the bases will be
loaded for bryce harper cold strike
three
frozen with a fastball two away
harper continues to struggle a huge
strikeout from hernandez
oh that one came inside and that's gonna
score a philly's run
hoskins was hit hernandez had something
to say about it to scott berry the home
plate umpire
perhaps saying he didn't get out of the
way but the run will score
as marshawn comes across the plate and
the lead is cut to one
the time runs at third now well he's
complaining hernandez is complaining
that he swung
so they're loaded it's a one-run game
and here's miller balls two strikes
here's the pitch swinging a miss at a
high fastball got him to chase one up in
his eyes and
darwin's embarks as he leaves the mile
however the phils do get a run
the winning run is aboard for bryce
harper
one swing of the bat everything is
forgiven a 1-2
[Applause]
bouncing ball right side grabbed by
dahlbach throws to second
and he nearly pulled the defender away
that time run moves to third
in torreyas hoskins has been as clutch
as anybody in the philadelphia lineup
this year he's got the tying run with
two outs at third base
the one-two pitch swing and a miss he
struck him out in a curveball in the
dirt
vasquez has it throws the first ball
game
over had him all the way it was
treacherous
in the night but uncle charlie bales
barns out
the phillies strand two in the ninth 4-3
the final